when we discuss colonial powers divvying
up continents it's almost always in
reference to africa or the americas and
whilst these are the continents that we
often think of antarctica was and also
still is divided the continent is split
like this with these countries all
claiming a chunk of it for their own and
with this last bit having no official
claimants but how did this come to pass
why is antarctica still divided why by
these countries in particular and why is
some of it still unclaimed so going back
the first person to discover antarctica
is controversial in 1819 william smith
discovered these islands just off the
coast of the continent but it was the
next year when russian explorer fabian
bellinghausen was the first to see the
actual continental landmass after it had
become clear that there was a lot of
land just sitting there without european
flags nations became very interested in
it so by the 1930s antarctica had been
thoroughly explored with the norwegians
being the first to reach the south pole
in 1911 by which time the british had
laid claim to this part of antarctica
because they wanted to tax the whaling
there and after this there was a sort of
scramble for antarctica and by 1939 the
french had laid claim to this the
norwegians this and germany this with
britain and its dominions having most of
the rest as you know 1939 also brought
world war ii which as a result meant
that these nations were much less
interested in antarctica and more
interested in not dying and during the
war argentina and chile asserted their
own territorial demands in the region
which overlapped with britons which
meant that it looked like conflict was
brewing after the war the united states
started to wipe the continent and made
large-scale expeditions which worried
the rest of the claimants the americans
began these exercises to help them if
they wanted any land for themselves and
also it acted as practice for what
antarctic conditions were similar to
arctic ones and if the us ever went to
war with the soviet union it was
believed that places like greenland
would be fought over the addition of one
of the world's superpowers meant that
the rest of the claimants got a bit
nervous and so there was a concerted
effort to negotiate a treaty this wasn't
just to stop the united states from
grabbing at all but to prevent the ussr
and japan from making their own claims
so the international treaty the
antarctic treaty was signed by these
nations in 1959 and it did several
things first of all it banned any new
claimants on the continent with the
exception of the usa and the ussr who
could do so in the future if they wished
importantly it didn't recognise any
nation's claims it just kicked the can
down the road second the treaty
demilitarized the continent banning
military bases and nuclear testing there
and third the treaty made antarctica a
scientific haven whereby research would
be the primary interaction that the rest
of the world had there and what this did
was put a stop to any further claims
which is why antarctica is divided up
like this but in practice not so much i
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with a special thanks
to my patrons james bissonette mr wolfe
kelly moneymaker sky chappelle jerry
lamdin jordan longley adam stalter corso
wolfe gareth turner marvin castell wyan
hockey captain cydog spencer lightfoot
boogery wiggly matthew shipley maggie
paxkowski aaron the white robert wetzel
marcus anthony beckett alex schwinn the
muk whopper gustav swan coppertone
spinning three plates moe winston
cayward charles the first ben evanson
and scottish trekkie